faire des tests robert lacombe
l'ingénieur et inspecteur en bâtiment a
fait du radon sa spécialité
le gaz est incolore inodore et
radioactifs il est présent dans les
maisons et si on est et rhin sont
dispendieux en creusant la terre puis
après ça ou ce que j'existe c'était des
caveaux apata maintenance et des salles
de jeux us et des chambres qu on utilise
beaucoup notre sous-sol de maison dont
on s'est rapprochés on veut dire de la
situation radon ce gaz se retrouvent
dans les maisons soient part parce qu'il
traverse par des fissures dans le salage
des maisons soit encore parce qu'ils
arrivent par l'eau par un puits artésien
or avec la pandémie santé canada met en
garde les canadiens qui sont en
télétravail une plus longue exposition
au radeau contribuer au risque de
développer un cancer du poumon à long
terme quand on le respire il va induire
à force une exposition prolongée puis
puis six sites en grande concentration
il va induire des mutations dans les
poumons qui vont donner éventuellement
des tumeurs du cancer du poumon on dit
pas qu'ils vont avoir le cancer du
poumon de me maintenir parce qu'on sait
que c'est une mesure c'est un long terme
que nous anime mais il faut y penser
parce que on n'est pas parti sur le bon
chemin
au québec une résidence sur 10 à une
concentration trop élevée au radon mais
comme les taux de radon varie d'une
maison à l'autre
santé canada recommande d'effectuer un
test comme celui ci l'activation de tous
on le met dans l'atmosphère ou ce qu'on
soupçonne du radon est celui-là 90 jours
des travaux peuvent aussi être effectuée
pour extraire le gaz novembre étant le
mois de sensibilisation ou radan santé
canada a distribué 1.6 million de tracts
au pays
et si camille simard radio canada québec